there is Beauty in everything but not
everyone can see it
confidence breeds Beauty
is like a precious stone the simpler it
is the more precious it is
Beauty Begins the moment you decide to
be yourself
outer beauty attracts but inner beauty
captures
no Beauty shines brighter than that of a
good heart
a beautiful face will age a perfect body
will change but a beautiful soul will
always be a beautiful soul
it awakens the soul to act
beauty is power a smile is its sword
Beauty starts in your head not in your
mirror
Beauty can be bold or natural but it
always has to be in harmony with the
individual
create Beauty inside and you will look
beautiful on the outside
a flower does not think of competing
with the flower next to it it just
blooms
there is no cosmetic for beauty like
happiness
without Grace Beauty is an unbaited hook
zest is the secret of all Beauty
there is no beauty that is attractive
without it
wisdom is the abstract of the past but
beauty is the promise of the future
some people no matter how old they get
never lose their beauty they merely move
it from their faces to their hearts
love of beauty is taste the creation of
beauty is art
our hearts are drunk with a beauty our
eyes can never see
inner beauty too needs occasionally to
be told it is beautiful
you were not born with beauty your
beauty is created by Who You Are
judge Nothing by the appearance the more
beautiful the serpent the more fatal
it's sting
Beauty and Folly are generally
companions
there are always flowers for those who
want to see them
taking joy and living is a woman's best
cosmetic
we often neglect to find the beauty and
things we see every day
moments of beauty sustain us through
hours of ugliness
the mirror is the worst judge of true
beauty
as we grow old the beauty steals inward
force yourself to find something
beautiful in everything you do and you
will only do beautiful things
whenever you are creating Beauty around
you you are restoring your own soul
a woman whose smile is open and whose
expression is glad has a kind of beauty
no matter what she wears
there are no ugly women there are only
women who do not know that they are
beautiful
the best cosmetic for a woman is love
but commercial Cosmetics are cheaper
each of us needs Beauty as well as bread
places to play and pray where nature
heals and gives strength for body and
soul
look for beauty not only in the object
itself but also in the form of its
shadow the combinations of light and
darkness that it creates
there can be no real beauty without a
little imperfection
beauty is something mysterious and
magical it enlivens the soul and the
world around us
beauty is a rare gift that needs to be
kept and appreciated every day
there are no ugly women only lazy ones
taking care of beauty we must start with
the heart and soul otherwise no
Cosmetics will help
the most valuable thing in a person
never catches the eye
there are people who look like Windows
their beauty is revealed thanks to the
light coming from within
many complain about their appearance but
no one complains about their
intelligence
the one who is not led to Beauty often
possesses it
to be loved it is best to be beautiful
but to be beautiful you need to be loved
it is known after all not what is
beautiful but what you like
everything you look at with love seems
beautiful
there can be no beautiful eyes that have
never cried
there is nothing more attractive in the
world than naturalness
people would see a lot of beautiful
things around them if they weren't so
angry
the voice of beauty sounds quiet it
penetrates only the most sensitive ears
sometimes something seems beautiful
simply because it is slightly different
from the surrounding objects
tearing off the petals you will never
know the beauty of a rose
we admire Beauty but we love kindness
beauty is deceptive but it is a valuable
quality if you are poor or not very
smart
for a woman beauty is more important
than the mind because it is easier for a
man to look than to think
the future belongs to those who believe
in the beauty of their dreams
there is more Beauty and truth even if
it is terrible beauty
is a queen who Reigns for a very short
time
Beauty does not require sacrifice it
requires money
the most beautiful beauty is good
behavior he who does not possess this
does not possess Beauty
a beautiful woman is Heaven for the eyes
hell for the soul and Purgatory for the
pocket
painting allows you to see things as
they were once when they were looked at
with love
a woman who considers Beauty to be a
virtue declares that she does not have
more dignity
hygiene is the best Cosmetic in the
world the most fruitful creator
the sign of a beautiful person is that
they always see Beauty in others
a beautiful wife who is also Faithful Is
as rare as a successful translation of a
poetic work
men notice the Beautiful Soul of a lady
only when that soul is in a beautiful
body
Beauty for a woman becomes a problem
only in two cases
when there is no Beauty and when there
is nothing but Beauty
true beauty does not need any decoration
it is enhanced by the lack of jewelry
he who does not want to see Beauty in
the simple does not know the true value
of beauty
thank you for watching which quote did
you like best let us know in the
comments